us präsident donald trump hat insidern
zufolge die aufnahme von migranten aus
haiti und afrikanischen staaten in
zweifel gezogen und diese als drecksloch
länder bezeichnet einem der beiden
insider zufolge sagte trump bei einer
besprechung mit zwei senatoren im weißen
haus warum wollen wir diese leute aus
afrika hier haben das sind drecksloch
ländern wir sollten mehr leute aus
norwegen haben
der zweite mit der unterhaltung
vertrauten person zufolge zog prompt
zudem in zweifel dass menschen aus haiti
in die usa kommen sollten
eine dritte person sagte trump habe
gefragt warum die usa ungelernte
arbeiter aus den betroffenen ländern
aufnehmen sollten anstatt migranten aus
staaten willkommen zu heißen die
qualifizierte arbeitskräfte anbieten
können
trump habe nicht beabsichtigt jemanden
mit seinen äußerungen zu beleidigen
ein sprecher des us-präsidialamtes sagte
bestimmte politiker in washington haben
sich entschieden sich für andere länder
einzusetzen aber präsident trump wird
immer für die amerikaner kämpfen
die reaktionen aus haiti ließen nicht
lange auf sich warten
der linke aktivist rené zivil fand
deutliche worte wenn die haitianer die
vereinigten staaten verlassen würden
wäre das kein geschenk sie sind ein
wichtiger faktor in der amerikanischen
wirtschaft und nicht nur als
arbeitskräfte
sie investieren in die vereinigten
staaten sie sind wichtig wenn alle mit
geld das land verlassen würden wurde
donald trump das nie akzeptieren
aber natürlich macht er denjenigen die
kein geld haben das leben schwer
weil donald ein rassistisch auch der
frühere mexikanische präsident vicente
fox sparte nicht mit kritik am us
präsidenten
auf twitter schrieb er an trump
gerichtet dein mund ist das schmutzigste
drecksloch auf der welt